basándonos en los datos de abajo que
estudiante mejoro más su calificación
entre el examen de mitad de período y el
examen final así que nos dan esta
información en términos de una gráfica
de barras para cada estudiante de hecho
tenemos dos barras verdad el que nos
representa en azul el examen de mitad de
período y el final que está en rojo así
que de hecho a veces a esta le llaman
una gráfica de barras en dos columnas
porque para cada estudiante tenemos dos
columnas de datos así que si fuéramos a
mirar los datos por nuestra propia
cuenta en realidad lo que nos piden es
checar quién es el que subió más su
calificación así que si miramos a yasmín
primero vamos a fijarnos primero aquí
podemos pensar que en el la mitad de
período que es la de la izquierda parece
como que estamos no se dejen adivinar
cómo que tiene 72 o 73 y digamos
no sé exactamente el número y pero eso
aparece no quizás en el final ella
obtuvo como 78 aproximadamente
y así que subió cinco puntos de mitad de
período al final no sabemos el número
exacto pero esto no es súper preciso
pero no no va a hacer falta saber los
números así que ahora fijémonos en jeff
jeff de hecho salió un peor bajo su
calificación él tenía digamos como 185 y
bajo este como año 84 no sé así que
definitivamente ya no él no mejoró su
calificación pensemos ahora en edin
parece kennedy mejoró la misma cantidad
que jasmine verdad digo no sé si te
vienes hombre es chico o chica este en
fin pero el punto es que parece como que
mejor o lo mismo quizás mi verdad
digamos que sí aquí tenía 83 y subió a
88 sólo estoy estimando digamos estoy
tratando de fijarme en el eje y para ver
cuánto vale así que neven y jasmine
hasta ahorita están empatados están
empatados ahora fijémonos en alejandra
bueno ella sí salto
calificación mejoro dramáticamente de
mitad de período al examen final parece
que a mitad de período obtuvo como un 81
82 digamos 82 a mitad del periodo y en
el final ella obtuvo un 95
así que subió muchísimo su calificación
así que alejandra es nuestra candidata
para hacer la que más ha subido su
calificación y finalmente marta aquí
definitivamente se ve que bajó su
calificación de mitad de período al
final ella estaba como noventa y altos y
después bajó a noventa y pocos así que
la ganadora aquí es alejandra alejandra
es la que mejoró más su calificación
entre el examen de mitad y el final